[Music]
to k-19 Vivat New Year Happy New Year we
out here in 2019 back with another
podcast welcome guys happy New Year and
welcome
I feel welcome well also welcome you
thank you this episode is brought to you
by farmers dog love your pets start
feeding them great amazing healthy food
provided by farmers dog is a company
that delivers pre-made whole ingredient
dog food to you at your house so you
don't have to go to the store and find
it and it's a customized meal plan for
your pet so you can give them the food
that they love our dogs are crazy for it
we feed them the food of Sam it's the
food of Salmons it is the food of
Simmons we feed them farmers dog and we
have ever since the farmers are exposed
to the podcast right now get 50% off
your two week trial of fresh healthy
food and the farmers dog calm slash
Jenna Julianne the farmer's daughter
confidently also guys a new sponsor this
week if you're looking to get your
fitness resolution on track and you're
you're nervous about signing up for one
gym or committing to one thing with all
the membership fees and the monthlies
and the this and that look no further
because class pass is an all-access
membership to over 14,000 of the best
gyms and fitness studios all over the
world and what they do is you sign up
with class pass and you pay just
starting at $15 and you can cancel
anytime per month but you pay that month
that monthly fee and what you do is you
get access to all the different options
for gyms for classes you can do yoga
strength training spin bar whatever you
even boxing they have all sorts of
options right now get your first month
for free by going to class pass calm
slash try slash Jenna Julianne that's
class pass calm slash try slash
annejulien or click the link below is a
really cool idea actually because it's
like signing up for a gym without
committing to one gym and you get all
the options also guys post mates if
you're done working out and you want a
burger or pizza or healthy food or
anything from the grocery store our
postman says there deliver it to you 24
hours a day 365 days a year post mates
does not take a day off they are ready
to deliver to you all the time
it is a great service we use it all the
time postmates says giving you $100 of
free delivery credits for your first
seven days when you sign up and use code
Jenna Julian on the post mates app check
it out thank you sponsors thank you
sponsors it's pretty rad
well Julian how was your break we back
we're back we're back I I feel good I I
feel refreshed and excited to come back
the break you know I don't think any
vacation or time off ever goes exactly
how you think it's gonna go but it was
good and like I feel good and I'm happy
to be back I did miss the podcast I
missed you guys
I just posted my first video of the year
and streamed a little bit when she wrote
you wrote your first radio show of the
year yeah I have not done a main channel
video yet this year but I'd say that's
the main source of my stress about going
back to her cuz that is like it's really
taxing after 50 weeks in a row you know
it was really ready for a yeah a couple
weeks off from that you could put him in
his bag okay there's a bed for dogs on
the floor sure you can he gave me a my
shirt he wants to go back to where he
came from that's not right in my shirt
that's not right
but like I don't know I I've had a
really great time with my family which
is really special because I don't get to
see them very often and uh with the my
niece and nephew which is really fun and
it's for your own the one-year old I got
to do just enough amount of nothing to
where I needed a mental break and just
to relax and you know we watched a movie
we watched a movie we watched bird box I
only be closed to movies technically
movie oh yeah Bandersnatch fantastic by
the way um I wasn't a super fan of bird
box nor was I
well the only reason that I wanted to
watch it was a because it was on Netflix
and be because I wanted to understand
the memes that everyone was tweeting I
felt really left out so we sat down and
watched it and I thought it was scary
the whole time but there's so many
potholes and it really bothered it also
reminded me too much of the happening by
I'm not I'm night gem lon featuring Mack
Wahlberg EMI Walken everyone walking
backwards and Mark Wahlberg doesn't know
it's trying to kill me in my sleep are
you what no man we're not what else to
say something like that she's like what
no yeah no only thing I remember from
that movie is that guy riding the
tractor he gets off and runs himself
over oh sorry
yeah it was just a little bit of a I
don't know I've seen that concept before
Sandra Bullock fantastic amazing to see
a younger generation finally appreciate
Sandra Bullock I appreciate her what I
know who wouldn't know it's her we know
you do yeah you of all people appreciate
Sandra Bullock Julie Roberts Indian
Hathaway they're a good person it was a
good it was an entertaining movie there
were parts of it that were like cool and
fun and you know a little stuff I don't
prefer it well I didn't know it was
gonna be scary I don't think that was a
scary movie I don't think that I don't
like feeling fear at all even in the
slightest so it wasn't for me
fair enough there were there were
moments though where I appreciate it cuz
I thought that they were cool you know
it was entertaining but yes I agree a
lot of potholes and I think it was way
over hyped but Bandersnatch on the other
hand fantastic yes so cool but I just
think it was nice that like we had some
moments to like lounge around yeah I was
the point yeah we watched and watched
some stuff we wouldn't usually watch
although we would always watch black
mirror like we would a movie on Netflix
not really something that we would do
just know we like well will more than
likely go into the game room and play
some games yeah and if we were to
usually watch movies it would come maybe
at the end of a weekend night in the
living room but this was like nah we
woke up that was good I think I think we
put a lot of energy towards actually
focusing on relax SHINee doing that yeah
and it was good because I do feel I feel
good I feel good to go I know
I feel like you're kind of one of those
people that has a hard time like doing
nothing because you always feel like you
need to be doing something whereas me
I'm like desperate to get everything
done so I can do nothing so I love if
you're easily do anything it takes to
get to nothing it's so hard for me to
like you've taught me the skill of
nothing yeah of sloth and I didn't serve
for nothing it's nothing but it doesn't
serve for nothing dude it is hard for me
to do that I'm telling you like I'm
imagine trying to like literally do
nothing but then every ounce of your
being is just like well we could do this
or what if we got ahead with this here's
an idea here's a New Year's resolution
what about writing down this my New
Year's resolution is to grow seven
inches taller so I might as well just
lay down and rest cuz that's the only
way it's probably gonna happen I can do
it I believe in me no I really curious I
can okay alright I bet you a million
dollars that you can do it
I said doll hairs so just a pet people I
don't know doll hairs oh dollars not
dollars anyway anyways anyways so
although we did watch one movie your
girl downloaded all of season well okay
here's the thing
this doesn't need to be talked about at
all it's stupid I'm the only one with
this problem I imagine but I have Hulu I
have we have Vudu because we got that to
watch Jersey Shore and oh my god that's
the head is I was trying to remember why
we got voodoo and that's why it was to
watch yeah we don't have to do some
weird stuff so I always have this
problem and please tell me it's not just
me that I'll download something on the
iTunes Store to watch it like what I'm
doing cardio like on my iPad or you know
whatever and then I'm like on my couch
or something and I'd like to watch it on
my TV and I can't because you can't
chromecast something from Apple like I
don't have an Apple TV you know what I'm
feeling at this point I just have like a
collection of pieces of [ __ ] that none
of which will just go to my TV you know
well unless you have an Apple TV all of
that is either wash on your
I pad on a plane or it sits on your iPad
well this is one of the reasons that we
talked about but I was I was drinking
some wine when you weren't on an LM tea
the whole reason I watched Casablanca
and I was like alright I'm gonna watch
gone with the wind in another weekend
but I was it was on my phone cuz I
couldn't put it on the TV and I'm like
well I can't watch it so my father's
making me feel weird watching Casablanca
on your phone feels like a terrible
I think I'm whatsoever exactly I just
felt weird and bad about as I stopped
anyways I was I had been watching
ancient aliens although on Hulu and on
iTunes it says it's like season 13 or
something but on Vudu and another
platform it says it's like season 11 it
was very confusing to try and find the
season I was watching the most current
season the one in 2018 so I had not
watched the entire thing because
although I had already downloaded it on
Apple and intended to watch it while I
was doing cardio which takes me you know
at 30 minutes to an hour every time I'm
in there it's really difficult for me to
do cardio and watch ancient aliens
because I'm so invested and what they're
saying and what's going on but I start
peddling really slow yeah like something
really not helping myself whatsoever so
I was like I have some free time right
now I'm gonna knock out the rest of
these episodes right so I go to put them
on my TV on my Apple iTunes can't do it
okay let me download it on Vudu alright
so Julian's in the other room playing
tarkov which I can't play because I'm
not good at it so I'm just in the room
by myself watching the Italians and
because it's one of your guys's favorite
things I thought I would bring to you
from the most recent episode series
series season of ancient aliens some of
the more interesting things that I had
not heard before so this is effectively
our next installment of conspiracy
theory yeah I guess so
and I mean you know a disclaimer as
always I guess these are just for fun
I'm not telling anyone to believe
anything and these are more just like
some interesting thoughts there's not
even really a whole lot of theories in
here I'd say and you know I just I
always like conspiracy theories just
because I like to know what someone else
thinks and how they got there and why
they think that and just find them
interesting I'm not trying to spread any
misinformation so it's
really out of entertainment and but also
we're educating you this is this is fact
what we say goes
we are the conspiracy professors oh no I
don't watch in chileans but when I think
it's super fun when I'm in the room and
it's on and I'm not doing anything I'm
listening in exposing myself to the show
so there are parts of it that I feel
like are intriguing yes and there are
parts of it that I feel like are really
reaching exactly so well I think even
fans of the show like myself agree with
that statement and like some of it is to
like a point completely laughable like
you at one point came into the living
room and I was [ __ ] screaming and
dying laughing because there's an
episode you know like a lot of them were
there in Egypt there in Giza and they're
looking at the pyramids and then the
ending scene of this right is he's with
I think Raman Romani or something he's a
Egyptologist expert whatever you know
what however you say that nope I'm not
making fun of it I just never heard that
word in my life let me look this is how
much I know
geologists ologists Egyptologists
yeah an Egyptologist isn't any
archaeologists historian linguist or art
historian who specializes in Egyptology
I want to be a New Mexican
New Mexico lodgest boy what do you know
about New Mexico that makes you a new
Mex ologists louisia knowledge Asst okay
South Dakota gist I think that was North
Dakota South Dakota fun part of South
Dakota ology is that there is no North
Dakota ology I don't you know and I
think that's spreading this information
you better be careful this audience is
very they don't there's a private
meeting go um okay anyways so in the
last scene of this episode you know
because they they they go to Egypt they
talk about the pyramids for all of all
of this every season of ancient aliens
they talk about every of the season
yeah at different aspects of it but well
one of the things that I do mention is
you know one of those things that came
from that episode but it was really
funny because at the end of the episode
there's this beautiful shot of Giorgio
tsoukalos and Raman Romani I forget his
actual name I apologize the
Egyptologists that you'd expect expert
sitting at this like cafe at like sunset
like dusk like this beautiful setting
it's right in front of the pyramids and
it is just stunning and they're sitting
there clearly like at a table facing
each other the pyramids are in the
background and then they're having this
really deep conversation you know the
episodes over so they're sort of like
speculating about what this means in the
future and hoping that people will like
go back and sort of requestion
everything that they know about
Egyptology you're filming the wrap-up
yeah they're filming the wrap-up and I
see in I feel so bad that I don't know
his name Roman he's hand it was like
creeping up this hookah right and I'm
like is that is it you know and yeah and
it keeps sort of panning back to these
like normal shots of the two of them
just nodding their heads and I'm like no
way he's just gonna like blow that
hookah vape just like into the Pyramids
of Giza and the episode literally ends
he's like yeah I'm just I'm really
hoping that you know in the future we
can really go back and study what this
means and he's like chunks of fat cloud
roll credits do do ancient aliens do
honestly I don't know why I've never
ended an episode of LMT that way I was
screaming I was screaming it like but
like as a fan of the show like I enjoy
it I enjoy it for all of its like some
of its you know thought-provoking some
of it's funny some of its clearly reach
and whatever like you don't have to
believe it but I find it really fun to
watch and that was just to me like one
of my favorite moments of that show yeah
and no show ever makes makes that the
ending scene of an episode when they
when they talk without being a little
self aware right exactly it was great
anyways I will get into some of the
things that I found
interesting that I had not heard of
prior and if I hadn't heard of then
chances are maybe you haven't heard of
them either and would find them a little
bit interesting now some of this I just
pulled directly like for this whole
first part I just pulled some of this
directly from Wikipedia so it's not even
really like I'll just read go for it
yeah okay ah chime in so the first thing
that I found interesting was when they
worked I think it was the episode called
Earth's black holes which was fun fun
episode because most of us have heard of
the Bermuda Triangle right and I think
even in the past podcast we had talked
about the presence of another triangle
called the dragon triangle off the coast
of Japan or the devil sea south of Japan
you heard a few heard of that one too
remember it's like a similarly shaped
triangle well it's like much longer
where ships and planes I think mostly
ships have been reported mysteriously
missing no not all of them just like the
Bermuda Triangle it's like not people
fly across that thing all the time I
don't know how that works yeah but it's
like there have been things weird things
that have happened that people haven't
found the wreckage of the ship but it's
not like a you can't go there yeah you
know anyways so there's something called
the vile vortices which according to
Wikipedia a vile vortex is any of twelve
purported peculiar geographic areas
arranged in a pattern around the earth
the term was coined by Ivan T Sanderson
who catalogued them as sites of
unexplained disappearances and other
mysterious phenomena
Ivan D Sanderson asserts that the 12
vortices famously the Bermuda Triangle
are situated along particular lines of
latitude five of the vortices are on the
same latitude south of the equator and
five are on the same latitude to the
north the other two are the North and
the South Poles which we've gone through
that and other podcasts or you know I'm
sure a lot of you know there's plenty of
fun things going on in the North and
South Poles that people have theorized
have to do with magnetic fields and blah
blah blah whatever
fun fun the idea has been taken up by
other fringe writers who have argued
that the vortices are linked to subtle
matter energy ley lines or
electromagnetic aberration the
phenomenon is addressed as geometric
patterns as explored by Plato in the
book anti-gravity and the world grid
which now I want to read because I did
not know that that was a book anyways
here are the vile vortices the Bermuda
Triangle which I think people are
familiar with the Algerian megaliths
south of Timbuktu the Indus Valley which
is in the city of mohenjo-daro in
Pakistan that's on land
mm-hmm yeah so like there are five of
them are on the same latitude in the
north and five of them are on the same
latitude is in the south well I'll show
you a picture and maybe I can link to
these or something in the description so
you can see mm-hmm I'm not telling you
to think anything I think it's a fun
picture okay the hammock kulia
volcano is east of Hawaii and it's an
underwater volcano some of these have
written more about because some of them
don't have a lot of information on them
like what exactly are the disappearances
that you're referring to yeah that you
came up to these are vile vortices some
of them have more information than
others like obviously the bringer
triangle has more information than the
Indus Valley but this is just according
to Ivan T Sanderson the volcano east of
Hawaii is an underwater volcano that has
been the site of what this is claiming
is multiple disappearances both from see
as well as the sky the devil see which
is south of Japan so here's this in 1974
American paranormal writer Charles
Berlitz introduced the devil see in his
book their Bermuda Triangle Berlitz
claimed that the that nine modern ships
and several hundred cruise were lost
without traces between 1950 to 1954 and
in 1955 the Japanese government sent
kayu Maru number five to the sea for
investigating unexplained ship losses
but this ship vanished as well which is
similar to the Bermuda Triangle that
incident with the planes that went in
and then they sent another plane in to
go look for it and that one disappears
well after the incident Japanese
authorities have labeled
the sea as a danger zone an 8 in 1989
Berlitz claimed that the devil sea is
also called the dragon's triangle in his
book the dragon's triangle Berlitz
continued by theorizing that five
Japanese military vessels disappeared
while on maneuvers near Japanese Shore
in early 1942 here's some criticism
though in Daniel Cohen's 1974 book
curses hexes and spells it's reported
that legends of the of the danger of the
dragon's triangle go back for centuries
in Japan and its most famous casualty
was the number 5 Chi Yu Maru a
scientific research vessel which
disappeared with the loss of all hands
on September 24th 1952 but was such a
dramatic history one would expect
there'd be all sorts of information on
the subject especially in Japan but a
search completed by skeptoid author
Brian Dunning for books newspaper and
magazine articles on the dragon's
triangle came up completely empty until
a full 20 years after the loss of the
Chi Yu Maru apparently the story even
the very existence of this legendary
named region was not invented until very
recently research also explores natural
environmental changes as the cause of
such controversial anomalies in the
dragon's triangle one of the
explanations is the vast field of
methane hydrates present in the bottom
of the ocean in the dragon's triangle
area methane clathrates whatever that is
methane hydrate the hydrates gas there's
something like that it will explode when
it rises above 18 degrees Celsius or 64
degrees Fahrenheit methane hydrate gases
are described as ice Lake deposits that
break off from the bottom and rise
forming bubbles on the surface of the
water these gas eruptions can then in
interrupt buoyancy and can easily sink a
ship leaving no trace so debris another
explanation for this paranormal activity
could be undersea volcanoes that are
very common in this area is quite
characteristic for small islands in the
dragon's triangle too frequently
disappear and new islands to appear due
to both volcanoes and seismic activity
it should also be noted that because of
the location of the dragon's triangle is
not plotted on any official world map
the size and parameter may vary from one
source to another
hmm
underwater volcanoes hmm that's why out
mmm those exist isn't it like all the
seismic plates and stuff on almost yeah
liquid hot for magma comes up in McNew
islands forming new yeah for me oh yeah
yeah wait so how would the methane
hydrate leave no trace if it destroyed
like a ship you know I don't know cuz I
feel like if it exploded a ship because
it like reached uh there'd be something
to breathe yeah or some sort of remnants
of I don't know well this is what it
says on Wikipedia no idea no I'm with it
another another one of the vile vortices
is the South Atlantic anomaly which is
really interesting to people that like
space that like electromagnetic fields
that like UFOs that like all this stuff
this slide is really fun to me the South
Atlantic anomaly is an area where the
Earth's inner Van Allen radiation belt
comes closest to the year surface
dipping down to an altitude of 200
kilometers this leads to an increased
flux of energetic particles in this
region and exposes orbiting satellites
to higher than usual levels of radiation
oh sure
the effect is caused by the non-consent
concentricity and like non-constant
whatever of the earth and it's magnetic
dipole the sa-ay are South Atlantic
anomaly is near is the near-earth region
where the Earth's magnetic field is
weakest relative to an idealized earth
centric dipole field okay so here's what
a band Allen the radiation belt is it
basically looks like if you can imagine
a bowtie earth is the center of it and
the radiation belt sort of bows out a
Van Allen radiation belt is a zone of
energetic charged particles most of
which originate from the solar wind that
are captured by and held around a planet
by that planet's magnetic field Earth
has to such belts that comes out the
bowtie and sometimes others may be
temporarily curie created the discovery
of the belts is credited to James Van
Allen and as a result Earth's belts are
known as the Van Allen belts the South
Atlantic
is one of great significance to
astronomer anomic all satellites and
other spacecraft that orbit the Earth at
several hundred kilometers altitude
these orbits take satellites through the
anomaly periodically exposing them to
several minutes of strong radiation
caused by the trap protons in the inner
Van Allen belt okay stay with me
astronauts are also affected by this
region which is said to be the cause of
peculiar shooting stars phosphenes seen
in the visual field of astronauts so I
guess there's a lot of claims of
astronauts hold on and effect termed the
cosmic ray visual phenomena passing
through the South Atlantic anomaly is
thought to be the failures of the global
star network satellites in 2007 but back
to the cosmic ray visual phenomena I
guess it's been reported that they'll
see like flashes of light even with
their eyes closed
astronauts yes wow they're out yes so I
think that that that's explained or it
can be scientifically explained but you
know for people that like that kind of
thing they're like wait so their eyes
can be shot and they'll still see yeah
apparently apparently there's been
reports so I have a question is : let me
just finish it the Pamela experience
experiment while passing through the
South Atlantic anomaly detected
antiproton levels that were orders of
magnitude higher than expected this
suggests that the Van Allen belt
confines anti particles produced by the
interaction of the Earth's upper
atmosphere with cosmic rays nASA has
reported that modern laptops have
crashed when the space shuttle flies
flies through the anomaly so good so if
it's exposing itself the anomaly if it's
exposing itself to satellites right your
satellites are exposing themselves to
the anomaly these satellites would they
lose signal are they are they
transmitting a constant video feed like
how I there any sort of proof in what
the satellites like are responsible for
that's that's sort of what I just read
read to you is that it's sort of like
the Bermuda Triangle right like lots of
things can pass through without a
problem or like be around it but there
have been some anomalies that have
occasionally happened because of the
high
level the normal radiation okay because
of the magnetic field okay I don't think
it's like an all the time thing
okay although I think on Wikipedia it
says that the one of the space stations
or something like frequently accounts
for it but others don't like other
satellites and other things don't
account for it and you might have like a
dropped feet or something yeah I don't
know I feel like in space like when you
have these satellites out there that are
just floating and they're unmanned right
there's no there's no astronauts
regularly on there maybe they're getting
it visited from time to time I don't
know how that works I don't know
whatever but I don't really know either
there are these unmanned well I have to
read more Wikipedia basically drones
right for lack of a better term out
there taking photos or doing whatever
imaging that they're doing yeah I don't
work in this I don't know how this I
know this all is so interesting to me
because even without like the conspiracy
part of it just like the the base level
of like how things operate in space
that's crazy to think about
well even NASA like there's just things
you can't account for that's what I'm
saying so like my question is like and I
guess it's not it's sort of rhetorical
but like you know the supposedly these
satellites are going through their zone
of whatever you want to call about then
Allen belts with all this but like yeah
like what if something happens to where
you can you can account for something
going wrong based on the recording being
altered or some sort of image or
whatever being transmitted in a
different way or a weird way or a weird
pattern or something cuts out or the
powers weird things yeah and like yes
this is totally likely in my mind
because I know nothing that's totally
likely but so is like the sky's the
limit
this guy's the universe is the limit
it's past this guy you know what I mean
like there's so many different things
that could be just it just kind of bends
my mind about what I like about some of
these theories though is that like this
is all really scientific and real you
know this is accepted that solar winds
can affect the Van Allen belt or
whatever you know that they act a little
weird sometimes because science is weird
yeah on a subatomic level and and on a
huge [ __ ] level
science is weird sometimes there's just
something we can't fully figure out or
explain but like why is that okay but
like if if a plane disappeared in a
Bermuda Triangle it's complete nonsense
you know like why can't there be things
that we can't explain that are just
around
well sort I mean to kind of bring back
that's why I like this well yeah and to
bring back the the issue of the triangle
and similar spots like that like
thinking about what could you know
anytime a flight goes missing mmm or an
aircraft but it happens in theory well
we don't know well it does happen
because define missing right it goes it
takes flight and it doesn't land and
there's no debris each other like that's
happened well there could be we just
didn't find it but my point is because
we didn't find it the definition is
missing mmm like I'm not that's not my
arguing point all I'm saying is like
that's happened before yeah things have
gone missing yeah yes and so just
because that's a real thing that has
happened and in my opinion one time is
enough times for that to be something
that everyone to be like has the right
to freak the [ __ ] out about seriously
like you know in these in these in these
areas or whatever you want to call them
to think that you could just get you
don't you don't even know you just get
erased or whatever you don't know so
that's another one which I think is
interesting because it's just
interesting another one of the vile
vortices is the Whorton basin which is
of interest in relation to the Indian
ocean floor movement and adjacent
fracture zones and the relationship
between the Indian and Australian plates
and is of one of a number of features of
the Indian Ocean that has been studied
extensively however its floor has not
been charted since the 1960s and is not
well known so it's a it's a instance
where you have tectonic plates moving
around yeah and some weird things that
might happen at the bottom the bottom of
your shoe yeah because I mean we have an
understanding of tectonic plates but
like do we really know how they work no
cuz if we did I don't know maybe we'd be
able to tell when an earthquake is gonna
happen I don't know I mean there's no
what a Richter scale is no that measures
our seismic seismic what
whatever we're just like - we're like -
dummy dum-dums talking about them just
like rattling off terms that we might
have learned in like what I mean you you
have a case under the ocean for where
you have a lot of energy happening with
a lot of tectonic plates going on who
knows what could go on you said that
area hadn't been cased or measured since
the 60s why is that not well I don't
know
and how often our bottom of the ocean
area is measured I don't know I don't
know the answer to that all I'm saying
is the Whorton Basin is considered one
of the vile vortices by Ivan whatever
his name is because there have been some
weird things what those weird things are
I don't even know he's just citing it as
one of the vile vortices and it's
tectonic plates Easter Island mm-hm but
I mean that's funny that you would
consider the Whorton Basin but also
Easter Island right like we don't know
why he doesn't think maybe there's a
book or something that can read because
none of these seem very compelling east
of Rio de Janeiro I don't know why the
loyalty islands I don't know why the
north in the South Pole and barring the
North and South Pole the remaining ten
vial vortices are approximately equal
distant and are equally scattered in the
two hemispheres on earth so there's two
charts I'll show you or there's like a
bunch of them but they're basically you
know they make like a pattern on the
earth and this is what it looks like if
it's flat they're all like this Wow
interesting interesting but does it make
any sense I don't know I just didn't
know that there were other places that
anyone considered to be a place of
anomaly and had charted them on like a
world map in any type of pattern I was
only really aware of the Bermuda
Triangle and the Dragons track yeah but
to see it all laid out guys definitely
something yeah and something that I
haven't seen either but it's also if
that's like somebody being like here's
the Bermuda Triangle
oh my god here's Easter Island look at
this be like that meme where you're
trying to connect all the dots on the
map yeah yeah but does it make any sense
I don't know but that's nuts right
because we are the experts
person's theory but uh the South
Atlantic anomaly is pretty cool and I
would love to fall into a hole about
that because that's I like that stuff
so anyways in that same episode Oh what
can I can I ask about a different
anomaly the one that I think I heard
when we were watching what the OPM
anomaly do you remember that overpriced
memberships offer gyms guys that is a
serious anomaly that is a real problem
overpriced gym memberships and you don't
have to deal with do this because do
what class pass is here to help by
taking all that hassle out all you have
to do guys is you sign up with class
pass starting at $15 a month you can
cancel anytime and then you get access
to classes and gyms all over the place
that isn't just one place that you're
paying an overpriced membership for it's
pretty great if you want to learn to box
sign up for class pass you'll get a
boxing class somewhere near you or yoga
or bar or spin or strength training
whatever you whatever your goals are for
the new year let class pass help you
guys you can get your first entire month
free at class pass calm / try / Jenna
Julian that's class pass calm / track /
annejulien or click the link down below
they've got something for everyone like
it's not just one gym or one style of
training they have a big variety because
not everyone's the same everyone has
different goals everyone has different
ways of achieving those goals and you
know what if you try class pass you
never know what sort of new workout you
might fall in love with and I think
that's the beauty of something like this
it's workouts and gyms and memberships
made very easy for you so check it out
click link below also guys what you got
to do now is since it's 2019 is you
going to start feeding your pet better
food okay because whatever you're
feeding I'm not judging but I know I
talked to your dog and I think they they
would appreciate some farmers dog for
whatever reason there's marketing out
there that convinces dog owners to feed
their dogs highly processed kibble and
nonsensical food like that but the
farmers dog is here to be like no that's
not what you're supposed there's they
want real food
so what you do is you go on the farmers
dog.com okay and you complete a short
questionnaire about your pet or pets
their size their eating habits their
what they like to eat what they don't
like to eat when they eat and the food
arrives at your door it's a customized
meal plan of real Whole Foods made in
little convenient pouches for your
animal you pull them out of the freezer
put them in the fridge then it before it
defrost put it up in their little bowl
and they eat it up they love it they
will like thank you so many times with
kisses and and snuggles so check it out
by going to the farmer's dog calm slash
damage will you get 50% off your
two-week trial fresh healthy food at the
farmer's dog calm slash Jenna Julianne
you and your puppy will be happy you
made that switch also guys post mates
for whatever you need delivered to your
house whether it's fast food or slower
food or really slow food or groceries or
something from the drugstore post mace
is there to bring it for you
it is a crazy crazy convenient simple
app you log on to the post minutes app
on your phone look through the
restaurants in your area choose from the
menu and then BAM a postman goes to pick
it up and bring it to your door in no
time it is so convenient they never take
a day off and you get a hundred dollars
of free delivery credit during your
first seven days when you sign up and
use Jenna Julian as a code on the post
mates app check it out or you know what
let's just say salads all right if you
want to start the New Year's with some
salads they also deliver salads but then
next week if you want some ramen you can
have that too check it out link below
thank you guys thank you sponsors so
after I just showed you that map I did
recall that I have seen a map like that
before on ancient aliens that was like
gave me a similar feeling to where I was
like why are you connecting those ones
and not those ones and it was a map of I
just found it this is on vortex maps
calm where they connect yeah they
connect certain megaliths around the
world globally that make this like
lattice formation around the world but
like why would you connect okay use a
Great Pyramid of
he's a Lake Baikal USSR many unique
plants and animals what it sounds like
you're just filling in a hole that that
Hudson Bay what you just said the most
arbitrary thing you've ever heard right
but I mean I have seen maps like that I
just hadn't seen one of the vile
vortices but yeah this I have seen ones
maps that connect megaliths before huh
all right yeah interesting interesting
it makes a cool pattern not a hundred
percent sure it doesn't spell out the
word aliens or anything like that okay
it's just like a pattern of what you see
it's interesting
okay anyways also from ancient aliens
episode talking about Earth's black
holes yeah this is actually cool though
when when scientists at the Department
of Energy's SLA see National Accelerator
Laboratory focused the full intensity of
the world's most powerful x-ray laser on
a small molecule they got a surprise a
single laser pulse stripped all but a
few electrons out of the molecules
biggest atom from the inside out leaving
a void that started pulling electrons
from the rest of the molecule like a
black hole gobbling a spiral disk of
matter within 30 femtoseconds millionths
of a billion billionth of a second the
molecule lost more than 50 electrons
four are more than scientists
anticipated based on earlier experiments
using less intense beams or isolated
atoms then it blew up so how intense
were the x-ray pulses they're about a
hundred times more intense than what you
would get if you focused all of the
sunlight that hits the Earth's surface
onto a thumbnail said LC repeat that
sentence please so the x-ray basically
that they aimed at an atom I think it
was a iodine I don't know oh no I'm not
sure but they they took a super-strong
x-ray and they pointed it at an atom and
it basically started stripping electrons
and then the electron stripped all their
electrons or something like that and it
created like a little electromagnetic
black hole but so when they were trying
to draw a comparison of what that what
that would be like in nature like if
that
to happen it's if you focus all of the
sunlight that hits the entire Earth
surface onto a thumbnail so this is
really super cool they made an
electromagnetic black hole but what's
really cool about that and what felt the
part of the episode was about that in
Einstein's theory not just gravity but
any form of energy if it's concentrated
enough could create a black hole so
you're thinking because they
concentrated so much energy in one small
tiny atom they created a black hole not
your thinking but that's what that's
right I mean that's kind of the theory
that they showed was that they created
an electromagnetic black hole like yeah
it took a lot of energy it's not quite
what they expected but in theory they
created an electromagnetic black hole
which a black hole in space when you
think about it is like a gravity black
yeah yeah so it's like not even light
can escape
it's just sucking everything in and
we're talking about like a molecular
level so right because there's yes
splitting yeah and so how did they
explain at least how it manifested or
how long it lasted or what oh gee blew
up but like there wasn't you said like
there was a femtosecond yeah of it
existing as a black hole then it blew up
is that what happened yeah I'm gonna use
femtosecond it said within 30
femtoseconds I'm right around the corner
be there femto but I remember it while I
was watching the episode I started
laughing at the sentence in Einstein's
theory yeah not just gravity but any
energy when concentrated enough can
create a black hole so like all y'all's
energy that you'd be bringing into 2019
be careful okay because it fits my
present rated enough you don't want to
create a black hole create a black hole
isn't that it's also just like a fun
metaphor of when you when you talk about
like the Twitter echo chamber of just
like nonsense and and garbage they're
just yelling at each other like if y'all
caught
trade that energy enough you gonna
create a black hole which I'm pretty
sure you did on Twitter hmm fun right
it is funny it's like brain brain candy
fun anything about it it's it's it's fun
that it also supported Einstein's
original theory which was that any
energy not just gravity if concentrated
enough could create a black hole an
electromagnetic black hole so then of
course ancient aliens takes this study
and they're like well we're gonna x-ray
this out in theory then in theory in
like a very far-reaching theory it's
possible that electromagnetic black
holes could exist on earth in space and
an ocean in the Bermuda Triangle like
all these you know stories that people
tell what we've talked about on the
podcast in the past about you know I was
just driving on the road and all of a
sudden now I'm missing time is it
possible that they're going through
electromagnetic black holes in various
locations where there is concentrated an
electromagnetic energy already created
black holes that now just existed maybe
well fun it is fun because of the fact
like to go back to what I was saying
like the first time I heard of like a
plane or an aircraft just vanishing in
air like where does your mind go right
so like that is a cool explanation to
think about that there was a you know
yeah well sure there's crazy amounts of
energy
there's tons of theories about that kind
of stuff about the Bermuda Triangle is
like a plane or like people that go
through wormholes and you know just the
fabric of time yeah
really fun it is fun you don't have to
think it's fun if you well I kind of
eight theories like well I can't I also
kind of want to go I want a deep dive
into someone's experience of missing
time that is so fascinating to me you
know what I mean look what does that
feel like
does it feel like you just dreamed or
you woke up from a dream there's lots of
accounts there's lots of accounts of
people that you know describe them
online but it's hard to know which ones
are real and which ones are real okay
next one yeah this is probably my
favorite new it's not it's I guess it's
a conspiracy theory my favorite new
conspiracy theory that
I've been exposed to in recent memory
brand-spanking-new it's not new though
brand new to me I'm off the press no
it's new to me are you ready yeah just
give me two seconds
I regret ever saying that word out loud
so you can use it okay it's about the
sphinxes head okay I've never been to
Giza I've never been to the pyramids I
have not seen them in person I've only
seen pictures and I've never questioned
them because you know I just accept okay
obviously ancient aliens goes over Egypt
and the pyramids a ton in there millions
of seasons but I was watching this
episode where they sort of just
mentioned something I had never heard
before which was what the hell is wrong
with the Sphinx his head in Giza the
body is huge it's a lion and then he's
got this tiny ass head and the Egyptians
never made anything look like that
everything is like super beautiful
yeah so here others I'll show the you
this picture this is the picture of the
Sphinx it looks like the dog sitting
down with with you know their it looks
like a dog the would the pose its in but
it's small hold on I'm just trying to
because it's widely accepted that it's a
lion's body with a pharaoh head yeah
yeah so they're sitting like this okay
oh yeah you can google a picture of the
sphinx it takes at least a couple
femtoseconds google but but look at the
size of his head
yeah he's in like tiny head mode yeah
he's in tiny head mode okay so this is
from ancient pages calm I have the link
here here his I don't have the name of
the writer he's from that website here
his gripes with regard and he's been
there the heads not that you need to go
there in order to see it the back is
flat whoever saw the back is flat
whoever saw a lion with a flat back
no big chest and no main the Sphinx is
sitting in a deep hole in the ground why
is that why is it not sitting somewhere
up high so that it can show off there is
a ruined temple right in front of the
Sphinx with a wall practically up
against its nose no door and that wall
why obstruct the view
of the Sphinx from the front like that
and if the temple was for worshipping
the Sphinx
why is there no access from the temple
to the Sphinx so that you can't even get
to it the pit in which this fig the
Sphinx sits seems to be deeply eroded as
if by flows of water what caused all
that it looks as if water has poured
down the sides on the other hand there
is no such vertical erosion patterns on
the Sphinx itself which instead has
clear horizontal erosion patterns how
can these two different patterns at
right angles to each be reconciled and
what could possibly have caused either
of them so here's that person's theory
because apparently there's been some
talk of ancient rain that has caused
this erosion of the Lion of the Sphinx
yeah
this person says I do not believe that
the Sphinx is 12,500 years old nor do I
believe in ancient rain I do believe
that the Sphinx is older than
conventionally believed but I do not
believe it is thousands of years older
or anything of that kind I do believe
there is water erosion at the Sphinx
site but I do not believe and had
anything to do with ancient rain nor do
I believe that there's anything to be
eroded at the time any ancient rain fell
the water of the Nile in those days at
the time of the inundation once a year
which no longer happens because of the
Aswan Dam came right up to the edge of
the Sphinx temple where there are even
quays in front of it I don't know what's
a Quay I don't know what that is I'm so
very sorry
so what I believe happened was that the
water of the Nile was let into the
Sphinx pit which I now called the Sphinx
moat by some simple water raising
devices led along the narrow channel
between the Sphinx temple and the valley
temple the two structures in front of
the Sphinx and its flow was controlled
by a series of slices and water gates I
don't know if slices either I feel
terrible the reason why the temple wall
is in front of the Sphinx is to act as
the fourth barrier to the water the
reason why there is no door in the wall
is because it will let the water out the
horizontal erosion in the side of the
Sphinx where is not covered by
restoration stones is because the Sphinx
is sitting in the middle of a moat
filled with water the vertical erosion
on this
sides of the pit especially on the south
side is because of the continual
dredging of the moat due to the
windblown sand accumulating there every
time the moat was dredged water poured
down into torrents onto the sides
leading to vertical erosion accentuating
by the natural cavity cavities in the
limestone bedrock so I think the Sphinx
was amongst other things and Island oh
my god this immediately solves the
puzzle of the evidence recorded by the
5th century BCE Greek historian
Herodotus I'm so sorry who said that
King Cheops I'm so sorry let the water
in from the Nile to surround an island
at Giza and here it is Cheops is head
the size of a pimple on the front of his
large flat back the lion surrounded by
water what's going on ok so then there's
this long long story about you know the
the guy that found the Sphinx it was up
to its neck in sand and then you know
the head that was currently on it he
thought was from the old ages but it
actually was from the Middle Ages I
don't know it's a super long story
basically you can read about that if you
want you don't have to some say it's
Cheops king Cheops his head some say
it's King HFF friend's head but if
you've ever seen King jump Efford his
head on the statue of Cairo Cairo Museum
you know they look nothing alike at all
bla bla bla bla bla it's a long story
anyways the theory is that the original
head of the Sphinx is Anubis what does
that mean Anubis the god Anubis is a No
the Sphinx is crouching at the there at
the entrance to the necropolis like a
guardian while there it is he's a guard
dog the ancient Egyptians had a god
called Anubis who was a crouching wild
dog generally referred to as a jackal
although strictly speaking there are no
jackals in Egypt and Anubis was really a
wild dog speech species which is now
extinct so there's a drawing it was
really interesting to me because this is
what it would look like if it had an
anatomically correct size Anubis head
like a big dog head with that flat back
not like a lion and then there's hole 9
I'll get to it in figure 1 I show the
drawing where I commish
which not me the author of this article
which shows how the recarved head of the
Sphinx was carved out of the neck stump
which remained on the Sphinx after the
original statue was mutilated by the
rampaging mobs who smashed up everything
they could on the Giza Plateau during
the period of chaos known as the first
intermediate period between twenty two
thousand and two thousand BC so that's
what this Sphinx would have originally
looked like with its original head
before King Geoff's our King chin Efrain
or somebody later on was like make that
big statue my head so before my head on
it the theory is that it got destroyed
and then repurposed into like reshaped
sculpted it wouldn't it make sense in
original Egypt for it to be Anubis
so that this is just this is arguing
that the statue wasn't built in its in
its initial state like it is now correct
and then it was not a lie and in
restructure yeah that it's not a lion at
all it's a new basis because that makes
a lot more sense well the jury's also
like a really interesting theory there's
tons of theories about what's under the
Sphinx and like secret passages and
tunnels and some of them were made after
so you don't know what's what and blah
blah blah but there's also a theory that
there's a second Sphinx somewhere
because all of ancient Egypt was like
really symmetrical for the most part I
like that thirty-two but I don't know
anything about it so I just threw it out
there it was the easiest thing in the
world to knock the ears in the nose off
the Sphinx when the Sphinx was Anubis
you couldn't put them back because the
Sphinx was carved out of solid bedrock
and the pieces must have been smashed to
bits anyways so the later exhibitionist
Pharaoh could even tell himself he was
doing a pious act restoring the statue
by flaunting himself now we have a
crouching Anubis as an island surrounded
by a little lake and at last we have
something which students of the ancient
Egypt Tech's can suddenly recognized for
the most ancient surviving Egyptian
texts known as the Pyramid Texts often
speak of a sacred place associated with
the Giza necropolis called jackal Lake
here it is fun right yeah I think I
think the most interesting part of this
theory is
potentially people who have studied
those pyramids and those formations for
thousands and hundreds in whatever years
have been studying the wrong thing well
that's like all of ancient aliens is
like they have the all the pyramids
wrong they're not tombs they're if you
put like hydrochloric acid on this side
and this gas on this side you basically
make a giant power thing like there's
tons of theories about how they have
everything wrong but who knows well yeah
I mean I think like well if you're to
look at that statue
it looks bizarre and you're like what is
that mm-hmm why is it why is the head
smaller why's that had a human on a
tiger lion whatever and it doesn't add
up so I think it's interesting to think
about why it didn't last in its original
state if its original state wasn't what
it is now yeah I don't know I just I
don't know if that's something that
people think or know of or like you know
if you went to visit the Sphinx if they
were like the original head is gone and
this head is here but we don't know what
the original head wasn't even know what
like is is talked about that no yeah but
I I personally did not ever hear of a
theory that it was Anubis and it's not a
lion I had always been taught that it
was a giant lion the island thing is
kind of whatever to me I think that's
just kind of reaching because I feel
like whatever lines or markings that
they attribute to it being underwater I
mean you can see there's like on the
walls of like the pit of where it's
sitting there's water erosion you can
tell yeah you know it's just it's just a
weird thing they're just weird like
that's the whole argument for the
pyramids it's like well if they were
built as tombs you know as people have
told us they were why didn't you find
anything why are there like in all of
Egypt there's all these hieroglyphics
like everywhere everything's beautiful
like and inside the pyramids there's
nothing there's no writing on the walls
there's no they never recovered any
bodies of kings and jewels and you know
yeah but they theorized the people went
in there ransacked everything but still
why is there no beautiful writing on all
the walls like they have in all the
temples and everything I don't know
whatever okay
I just thought it was really interesting
because I had never heard that the
Sphinx might actually in theory be
Anubis I mean fine if you're to look up
the image right we can try to link it
but what is the website again ancient
pages yeah so if you to look at that
image it does like the shape of the
article is called what was the Sphinx
and what's wrong with its body and head
yeah it looks more normal with the
mock-up of the tall ears and the longest
now in the flat looks like it's yeah the
flat back cuz that's how you know that's
how I feel like it the statue the rest
of the statue looks already that was
really fun and one of my favorite newer
things that I've wondered that I thought
was really interesting yeah because who
knows it could have been aligned and
that could be its original head for all
I know I don't know I just was always
taught in school that it was a giant
lion you know yeah remember I was taught
okay you have one more two but the last
ones really short oh yeah ah this again
take it with a grain of salt
whatever it is alright for decades
Americans were told that area 51 didn't
really exist and that the US government
had no official interests and aliens or
UFOs everyone that really believed the
stuff we're of like tinfoil hat people
for a really long time the Pentagon
officially confirmed that there it was
in fact a 22 million dollar government
program to collect and analyze anomalous
aerospace threats its UFOs and they
release that information in December of
2017 like literally last year December
2017 is when the Pentagon actually
admitted to this existing but all of us
have been aware of it right everybody
knew what area 51 was and you know
speculated what went on there so ancient
alien theorists have called this a
smokescreen to divert attention away
from areas 52 53 54 who knows right
right so most people are familiar with
area 51 some conspiracy surrounding it
include the storage examination reverse
engineering of crashed
spacecraft including materials
supposedly recovered at Roswell the
study of their occupants living and dead
like grey aliens if they had one you
know whatever and the manufacturer of
aircraft aircraft based on alien
technology people think that maybe there
were meetings or joint undertakings with
extraterrestrials the development of
exotic energy weapons for the Strategic
Defense Initiative SDI or other weapons
programs the development of means of
weather control the development of time
travel and teleportation technology the
development of unusual and exotic
propulsion systems related to the Aurora
program activities related to a supposed
shadowy one-world government or the
majestic 12 organization many of the
hypotheses concerned underground
facilities at groom or Papoose Lake also
known as the s4 location 8.5 miles south
and include claims of a transcontinental
underground railroads railroad system a
disappearing air stripped named the
cheshire airstrip after Lewis Carroll's
Cheshire cat which briefly appears when
water sprayed onto its camouflaged
asphalt an engineering based alien
technology publicly available
satellite imagery however is showed that
there's no treasure Kent airstrip
anyways what I saw in this episode was
about the Transcontinental Underground
Railroad situation going on under area
51 and there are people that have
hypothesized that it existed and I
thought that was cool you know but where
does all the dirt go just like everybody
else if you're building this gigantic
underground facility under area 51 or
other places how can we just teehee
where the government cover-up that we're
like digging miles and miles and miles
underground like that would look like an
enormous construction site no maybe also
here this is well this is the theories
do it until I heard this theory on the
show from a miner in Nevada specifically
Rachel Nevada outside of area 51 at the
Tempe mine that claims the government is
using a
process called heap leaching to get rid
of the dirt his name is heap leaching
heap like a big heap like a pile
leaching Kristen Christian gray no he's
a mine owner north of area 51
he says the area 51 you see on Google
Images is the 50s 60s and 70s they are
underground now so even if you were
looking at them from a satellite image
you wouldn't know they're building
underground so where is the dirt going
he claims that it's going into nearby
mines like the temp ute mine and using
heap leaching which is they pile up the
ore into a large mountain in the nearby
mines hundreds of feet high and then
they run hoses through it every two feet
or so and they leach in mercury and
cyanide and it takes boulders and
basically breaks them down into nothing
yeah but I think you're left over all of
my miner friends in the comments you if
you want to help chime in and don't
fully understand this process but I
think what you're like the process was
originally developed to take you know
enormous pieces of rock you take cyanide
and Mercury dangerous chemicals and you
inject them into this rock and it you're
left with the natural or so like gold
silver and all that because it breaks
down completely yeah but what you'd be
left with is the things you're looking
for but it's controversial isn't it
you're probably gonna poison some
drinking water you know you're probably
been destroying [ __ ] tons of land yeah I
don't know what ton about it but that's
just what this guy claims and to arouse
no suspicion of the local miners they
take all the gold and the silver and you
know whatever is left over from the heat
bleaching and they give it to the local
local miners as hush money basically and
what in their end of the deal like what
they're getting out of it is they get to
secretly do all this underground
construction
yeah and exploring yeah well because you
know in the middle of Nevada this is all
in theory none of this well no when is
this supposedly take place like right
now that's hard to believe
that they're giving people gold as hush
money right now gold maybe silver well
so listen but even anything is hash
money listen so if you're the government
right and you take in just mass
quantities of dirt underground and
you're doing this process in these
places where there's not a lot of people
living you know in this big vast desert
right
the only people because you can't see
them from the sky from the ground you're
you know none the wiser the only people
that could catch on to this is the
people that work in the local mines and
they're aware of you taking all this
dirt and he bleaching it so the only
people that you would need to hush up
are the people that are aware of that
hmm have there only been mysterious
disappearances among miners I don't
think so
but basically they had this person
Christian grew no on the show and he
said I've seen other miners take hush
money and they don't have a problem with
it you know interesting I just the only
thing that I found interesting was that
okay all of that's fine you know maybe
the government's building this big thing
underground whatever I did not know that
he bleaching was a thing that existed
that you could take gigantic quantities
of dirt or rock and shrink them down
into nothing it did not know that was a
thing with science science okay
so that's only the beginning though
because there are people that claim that
there's trains that go all the way to
Cheyenne Mountain in Colorado Springs
which is a mountain hollowed out by the
US military according to them to Dulce
New Mexico Los Alamos Albuquerque
Roswell and area 51 and that they're all
connected underground hmm and that is
currently operational it's a theory Wow
what people I mean the reason they had
the this as a segment on the show mm-hmm
was because of the disclosure by the
Pentagon in 2017 that area 51 does in
fact exist and you know you guys were
all right yeah we were lying we were
hiding
because there it's a smoke screen for
people to focus on what is or what isn't
actually at area 51 so that they could
continue secretly and secretly building
a tree chu underground Chu Chu I don't
know transporting things around the
southwest of America I guess so no one
else is supposed to see I guess reading
airfare in lines at TSA because they can
travel right I guess though yeah the
only takeaway that I found was
interesting was that I did not know that
you could do a process like that to get
rid of mass quantities they Rock what is
the process called again heap leach and
where did that come from mining Wow so
we're like what is the source for heap
leaching like miners are aware of that
process are they yeah I looked it up
just for a minute sorry I'm not an
expert on any of these things I'm just
doing new things I found interesting
heap leaching I looked up on Wikipedia
from what I read is was like a
breakthrough in mining you know cuz it's
pretty awesome but it's also kind of
controversial I can see that and that
there are apparently like some mines yes
as examples for okay let me read you
this fort belknap montana located on the
Fort Belknap Indian Reservation the sort
Minh Landowski gold mine in Montana was
one of the many early heap leaching
mines that experienced problems with
spills and contamination of surface and
groundwater
although the leaks happened in the 1980s
the mine was eventually shut down in
1996 health problems on the reservation
persist and is not all of the mine was
properly cleaned up could potentially
cause further damage of the people fort
belknap shortman Landowski eventually
filed bankruptcy when the Bureau of Land
Management stepped in to assist the
lawsuit that was not heard by the
residents of the reservation once the
bankruptcy was filed however all
healthcare and studies ceased and
compensation for the destruction of the
culturally significant mountain peaks to
the local s
oh boy and gross venture people was
never achieved today there are still
abnormally high reports of health
problems including thyroid problems lead
poisoning chemical burns and emphysema
especially in children hmm sounds
intense yeah so this says in the United
States the general mining law of 1872
gave rights to explore and mine on
public domain land the original law did
not require post mining reclamation mine
land reclamation requirements on federal
land depended on state requirements blah
blah blah currently mining on federal
land must have a government approved
mining and reclamation reclamation plan
before mining can start yes I'm not sure
if you can if it's actually illegal or
if it you know I don't think it's
illegal but I think that there are some
problems yeah it says heat bleaching
mining works well for large volumes of
low-grade ores as reduced okay yeah so I
think it's a thing ya know exists yeah
but it can be really dangerous and it
sounds like it's been theorized to be
the method of which the government might
be digging underground but it's it's a
it's a thing that mining companies use
because it's extremely effective Wow
right he please I didn't know was the
thing yeah yeah why are you screaming at
me anyways take that for what you will
so the last theory of fun this is
interesting UFO theorists have theorized
for ten years that it existed and in
2017 it was admitted by the government
that the advanced aerospace threat
identification program or a tip did in
fact exists the project was funded by
Congress in from 2007 to 2012 even
though there's people that believe that
it's still going on or something similar
is going on with the help of Senator
Reid of Nevada and involved a private
company Bigelow industries which is the
first time that that's ever happened
because usually you know if they're Wow
they're investigating aerospace you know
threat identification that's something
that the Pentagon or you know government
would handle and they wouldn't involve a
private
company like Bigelow industries yeah and
so people were like why would you do
that so if you take projects that are
developing from the Pentagon and you
move them into private industry you
remove the Freedom of Information Act if
if there's a government program going on
anybody can fill out a form and request
information on any government program
but if you're a private industry you do
not have to adhere to this because
according to exemption number four
involving trade secrets like Bigelow
industries you don't have to share any
information with anybody this is crazy
sex and like that kind of stuff they're
doing stuff not any they don't have to
adhere to the long as they're privately
owned a Freedom of Information Act that
is such an interesting thing though
because legal loophole well that means
that in an attempt to preserve trade
secrets or whatever they call it you're
now giving private companies all this
freedom to research whatever they want
research or whatever they want
ain't nobody's business but that's crazy
yeah that's crazy that that's an actual
legal loophole yeah so I mean obviously
there's people that go wild with that
theory and that they're doing this and
that and this and that you know
theorized whatever you want but I think
it is interesting it is definitely
interesting that like the SpaceX thing
that you told me the other day you're
like you know SpaceX it's privately
owned yeah so they're they they're not
they are not subject to having to give
overall I think they're subject to some
things but they're not subject to the
Freedom of Information Act which means
that they can keep their secrets in a
vault pretty much and whatever they're
doing right and whatever they're working
on or researching or well I'm sure
they're subject to a lot of things just
not the Freedom of Information Act hmm
pretty cool it was pretty cool
anyways those are those are some fun
things that I found that I thought were
interesting and they mean absolutely
nothing really mean what they mean what
you want them to mean or want to think
about like I think more and more I just
yeah I think these are all really good
for just thinking about letting your
your kind of your imagination but for
lack of a better word like kind of run
wild with it because I feel like there's
a lot of situations where you you know
you learn one new thing about I don't
know mining or space or therapy muna
triangle and it starts to take on a
whole new meaning for you mm-hmm
and I think that's what's cool about
these I do really like that Sphinx
theory though that it is actually Anubis
I think that's what do you think that
like that represented that like well
it's Anubis guarding the necropolis it
it makes sense that the Egyptians would
have built that like obviously the head
is something different
mm-hmm but I was always taught it was a
lion but that doesn't even make any
sense it's like I don't yeah of course
it's not of course its Anubis of course
it's not a lion what they're lions there
I don't think yeah like what meaning
would a lion had it have even had well
they would probably build a giant statue
of their God right of one of their gods
like all the hieroglyphics and
everything that they did you know just
beautiful pictures of their gods and
their religion and their people and then
this one random giant lioness lion right
place at the right time flying God let's
go for me you sure rolled through town
came legend that's cool though thank you
for sharing these nuggets of conspiracy
yeah wait I want to cut I'm kind of
curious now about what I just butchered
that spelling
sphynx how Fink's SP y SP hy SP h i and
x iy yeah it says a sphinx is ancient
Greek plural sphinxes or spin jizz is a
mythical creature with the head of a
human and the body of a lion in Greek
tradition it has the head of a human and
the haunches of a lion and is sometimes
wings of a bird so even the word Sphinx
even what we've been calling it means
the head of a human in the body so the
lion so that definition of his face
could potentially be like based on
something that wasn't even well yeah
it's clearly somebody was like ah dude
that's a sphinx that's crazy like cuz
this the Sphinx or - so to speak or the
human head on the lion body
happened because of an event where
someone just gotten destroyed
yeah well someone discovered it and they
were just like that's a space yeah
that's his Fink's that's crazy yeah so
it was probably if you will or maybe
they read it in a different way or shape
or form
yeah they well yeah they renamed it
after that the guy was like put my head
on there and now it's the Sphinx but
like the whole thing was a different
thing with a whole different meaning
beforehand yeah damned yeah people be
out here making fake definitions for
things they don't even know [ __ ] about
dawg
well now I'm looking at the the Sphinx
Wikipedia page of Egypt yeah it says cut
from the bedrock the original shape of
the Sphinx has been restored with layers
of blocks at measures 73 meters buh buh
buh it is the oldest known monumental
sculpture in Egypt and is commonly
believed to have been built by ancient
Egyptians of the Old Kingdom during the
reign of Pharaoh Khafre construction or
engine and identity commonly used named
Sphinx was given to it in classical
antiquity about 2,000 years after the
commonly accepted date of its
construction by reference to a Greek
mythological beasts with a lion's body
y'all really just be out here making up
names dude way after it was built 2,000
years mm-hmm
damn some early Egyptologists and
excavators of the Giza pyramid complex
believe that the Great Sphinx and
associated temples to predate the forth
okay yeah okay so people are saying it's
older but where's where's people being
like whose head is that whose head was
originally on it you know like I wanna
fringe hypotheses Orion correlation
theory why is that fringe the the
pyramids lined up with the constellation
of Orion at this time at what time in
relative positions occupied by these
stars yet the authors argue that the
geographic relationship of the Sphinx
the Giza pyramids and the Nile directly
corresponds with Leo Orion in the Milky
Way respectively sometimes said it is an
example of pseudo archaeology the theory
is that variants with main screen
scholarship okay on Wikipedia it says
this is a fringe hypothesis the Great
Sphinx as Anubis author Robert K G
temple proposes that the Sphinx was
originally a statue of the jackal dog
Anubis the god of the necropolis and
that the face was recarved in the like
likeness of a Middle Kingdom Pharaoh M
in Hemet to temple bases his
identification on the style of the eye
makeup and the style of the pleats on
the headdress interesting so that's what
Wikipedia meaning that's not that's like
but it's a it's according to Wikipedia
is a fringe theory but what is it
I'm Seri - a theory theory is a theory
in my opinion I mean at least with stuff
like this I don't think I don't know
what I'm talking about but I don't know
why can't it just be a theory yeah
that's my question - that's my question
- like maybe I don't know maybe it's
like afraid the writers they're not
trying to offend and yeah yeah exactly
they're trying to preserve whatever that
Sphinx or statue had meant to certain
people or whatever totally
anyways fun really fun
I like fun then we covered a wide range
of things today
all the way from space remember space
okay according to Einstein's theory if
any energy not just gravity including
areas energy is concentrated enough you
can't create areas like create a black
holes at some point so if you'll see me
I'll be in my black hole you know in a
femtosecond oh yeah I'll be a bag and be
a femtosecond hose okay bye
sick okay well I think you guys for
hanging out for the conspiracy Sphinx
femtosecond tectonic plates Adam
splitting podcasts we hope you enjoyed
your time we only knowledgeable you know
what if you wanted to find knowledge you
could go to places on the internet for
knowledge you come here because we're
will give them anyway thank you guys for
hanging out have a great week we'll see
you next week we'll talk about we'll
talk about all sorts of stuff we'll be
right back in a femtosecond see you
later
[Music]
you
[Music]